This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last summer, despite his better judgment, Brian Vance found himself in the situation that, unfortunately, many of us have been in, an argument with some random person on Reddit. Which is probably not the best thing to do. You know, getting into online fights is not a good use of anyone's time, and it's definitely not good for your blood pressure. Brian is a journalist based in Portland, Oregon, who founded some of the internet. something called Stumptown Savings.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。去年夏天，布莱恩·万斯在违背自己理智的情况下，陷入了我们许多人不幸经历过的境地：在Reddit上与某个陌生人争论。这大概不是什么明智之举。你知道，陷入网络争吵对谁来说都不是时间的合理利用，而且绝对不利于你的血压。布莱恩是一位常驻俄勒冈州波特兰市的记者，他创办了互联网上的某个东西，叫作“树桩镇储蓄”（Stumptown Savings）。
That is frequent 99PI contributor, Will Aspinall. Stump Town Savings is a website that covers local grocery deals. Every Thursday, Brian releases a newsletter where he helps his readers find the best food prices in the area. He read me a little snippet. Pantry through August 19th, Equal Exchange, chocolate bar, select varieties 399 each. Annie's organic salad dressing, select varieties two for eight. You can see this is pretty dry. There's not a lot that I can do to make it intriguing to read.
那是《99PI》的常客威尔·阿斯皮纳尔。树桩镇储蓄是一个涵盖当地杂货店优惠信息的网站。每周四，布莱恩都会发布一份时事通讯，帮助读者找到该地区最实惠的食品价格。他给我读了一小段。“食品储藏室，截至8月19日，Equal Exchange巧克力棒，精选品种，每块3.99美元。安妮有机沙拉酱，精选品种，两瓶8美元。”你可以看出这非常枯燥。我实在没法让它读起来引人入胜。
Once again, organic peanut butter, select varieties, $5.99 each. Yeah, I mean, I'm not under the guys that I'm going to win like a Pulitzer Prize in literature for this. In Middenby Faulkner, but Brian takes a lot of pride in his work, including visiting grocery stores in person to find the hottest deals for his readers. Stumptown Savings has become my full-time job. Like, I spend 40 hours a week doing this. Just trying to help people, like, have some say, have some power in what feels like a powerless struggle with, you know, corporate greed and inflation. As you can tell, Brian puts a lot of effort into Stump Town Savings. So he was particularly miffed when a user on Reddit accused him of the ultimate sin using ChatGPT to compose his newsletter.
再来，有机花生酱，精选品种，每瓶5.99美元。是的，我的意思是，我并没有自诩能凭此获得普利策文学奖。我不是米登比·福克纳，但布莱恩对自己的工作引以为豪，包括亲自走访杂货店，为读者寻找最热门的优惠。“树桩镇储蓄”已经成了我的全职工作。我每周花40个小时做这件事。只是想帮助人们，让他们在面对企业贪婪和通货膨胀这种看似无力的斗争中，拥有一些话语权，拥有一些力量。如你所见，布莱恩在“树桩镇储蓄”上投入了大量心血。所以，当Reddit上的一位用户指责他犯下终极罪行——使用ChatGPT撰写时事通讯时，他感到特别恼火。
Brian didn't use AI. but it wasn't just the accusation itself that he found offensive. It was the evidence the Reddit user provided to support his allegation. A Reddit user accused me of using AI, pointing to my use of, quote, extra long m-dashes that are not possible to replicate on a normal keyboard, end quote. So anyone who uses an MDash must be using AI, and that's just not the case. The reason why this Redditor believed Brian was using AI was because he chose to use an MDAS. The m-dash, if you're not familiar, is a form of punctuation that looks like a horizontal bar in a sentence.
布莱恩并没有使用人工智能。但他感到被冒犯的不仅仅是这一指控本身，还有那位Reddit用户用来支持其指控的证据。“一位Reddit用户指责我使用人工智能，并指出我使用了‘普通键盘无法复制的超长破折号’。”所以，任何使用破折号的人一定都在使用人工智能，事实并非如此。这位Reddit用户之所以认为布莱恩在使用人工智能，是因为他选择了使用破折号。如果你不熟悉的话，破折号是一种标点符号，看起来像句子中的一条横线。
It gets its name from its size, which is about the width of a capital M. Not to be confused with the hyphen or its persnickety cousin, the n-dash, m-dashes are incredibly versatile, because they can replace commas, colon, semicolens, and parentheses. It's an odd thing to be a fan of an M-Dash, but I am a fan of it. It's a fun piece of punctuation. There's a group of people who understand it and appreciate it and really value its flexibility. Today, there are many diehard fans of the M-Dash, but humans aren't the only ones who have taken to using the mark. Recently, large language models like ChatGPT, Claude, and Gemini have been sprinkling M's in their responses like digital confetti.
它的名字来源于它的长度，大约是一个大写字母M的宽度。不要把它与连字符或它那挑剔的表亲——短破折号混淆。破折号非常通用，因为它们可以代替逗号、冒号、分号和括号。成为破折号的粉丝是一件奇怪的事，但我确实是它的粉丝。它是一种有趣的标点符号。有一群人理解它、欣赏它，并真正重视它的灵活性。如今，破折号有很多死忠粉，但人类并不是唯一使用这个符号的群体。最近，像ChatGPT、Claude和Gemini这样的大型语言模型一直在它们的回答中像数字五彩纸屑一样撒着破折号。
There are some people who look at it and be like, well, an AI must have did this, because why would a human, use an M-Dash, but, you know, that's, I'm a human. I can confirm I'm a human. Today, we're reclaiming the M-Dash for Brian and other humans, because this plucky bit of punctuation has had a very, very long literary history way beyond today's tussles with technology. It's been on a hero's journey, playing the lead in an adventure story that has spanned both centuries and the pages of our most beloved plays, novels and poems. So, who invented it? And why? The MDASH's origins can be found in trying to find an elegant answer to a very old problem. The problem that existed was that there wasn't really a good set of rules for punctuating
有些人看到它会说：“嗯，这一定是人工智能干的，因为人类为什么要用破折号呢？”但你知道，我是人类。我可以确认我是人类。今天，我们要为布莱恩和其他人类夺回破折号，因为这种勇敢的标点符号有着非常、非常悠久的文学历史，远超当今与技术的纠葛。它经历了一场英雄之旅，在跨越了几个世纪以及我们最钟爱的戏剧、小说和诗歌页面的冒险故事中担任主角。那么，是谁发明了它？为什么？破折号的起源可以追溯到人们试图为一个非常古老的问题寻找一个优雅的答案。当时存在的问题是，对于标点符号的使用，并没有一套真正好的规则。
texts. There wasn't really any kind of convention that persisted for all that long, or that was usable across lots of different contexts. This is Keith Houston, author of the book Shady Characters, The Secret Life of Punctuation, Symbols and Other Typographical Marks. He says that while punctuation crept into writing systems around the 3rd century BCE, the rules that governed them remained both complex and inconsistent well into the 11th and 12th centuries.
文本标点并没有真正持久的惯例，也没有在许多不同语境下通用的规则。这是基思·休斯顿，他是《阴暗字符：标点符号、符号和其他排版标记的秘密生活》一书的作者。他说，虽然标点符号在公元前3世纪左右潜入书写系统，但支配它们的规则在11和12世纪依然复杂且不一致。
It was around that time, an Italian scholar decided to leave his mark on the world of punctuation. His name was Bon Campano de Signia. But we're mercifully going to call him Bonnie. He practiced something called Ars Dick Diminis, which was the formal art of composing letters and official documents. The problem was that he found the then system of punctuation not up to snuff for his letter writing.
大约在那个时候，一位意大利学者决定在标点符号的世界里留下自己的印记。他的名字叫博恩·坎帕诺·德·西尼亚。但我们仁慈地称他为“邦尼”。他实践了一种叫作“书信艺术”的东西，这是撰写信件和官方文件的正式艺术。问题在于，他发现当时的标点系统对于他的书信写作来说不够好。
So he came up with his own. And so when you had someone like Bonnie deciding to write a guide to letter writing, it was kind of up to him to decide how to punctuate things. And for whatever reason, he chose this very simple system. Bonnie created two punctuation marks. One he called Vergula Sersum erecta, which looked like a forward slash. That one indicated a pause in a sentence. The forward slash was eventually shortened and dropped to the bottom of the line,
于是他想出了自己的一套。所以，当像邦尼这样的人决定编写一本信件写作指南时，如何标点符号就得由他来决定了。出于某种原因，他选择了这个非常简单的系统。邦尼创造了两个标点符号。一个他称之为“向上倾斜的斜线”，看起来像一条正斜杠。那个符号表示句子中的停顿。正斜杠最终被缩短并降到了行底，
transforming it into the comma we all recognize today. It remains his greatest contrast. to punctuation, and if you're fluent in Italian, which I am not, you will know that Vogola means comma, and in French, it's Vigul. He also created a second mark called Virgula Plana, which was a horizontal dash that ended the sentence, like a period. And that is like a flat dash or a horizontal dash that looks exactly like a modern N or M dash.
变成了我们今天都认识的逗号。这仍然是他对标点符号最大的贡献。如果你精通意大利语（我并不精通），你就会知道“Virgula”的意思是逗号，在法语中是“Virgule”。他还创造了第二个符号，叫作“平坦的斜线”，那是一条结束句子的横线，就像句号一样。那就像一条平坦的横线，看起来和现代的短破折号或长破折号一模一样。
But using a dash at the end of a sentence did not catch on. And for several centuries, it was difficult to find consistent uses of the dash. Possibly, because the dash was not widely adopted, its grammatical role remained slightly unclear and therefore malleable. I don't think it's entirely unreasonable to look at the marks around it. So the full stop or period, the question mark, the comma, the colon, the semicolon. And to a certain extent, they were all not fixed, but in slightly more common use, whereas the dash seemed to have, you know, It slid into this new era of printing without necessarily a big weight of opinion behind it. So perhaps it seemed more flexible.
但在句末使用破折号并没有流行起来。在几个世纪里，很难找到破折号的一致用法。可能因为破折号没有被广泛采用，它的语法作用仍然有些模糊，因此具有可塑性。我不认为审视它周围的符号是不合理的。所以句号、问号、逗号、冒号、分号，在某种程度上，它们都不是固定的，但使用得稍微普遍一些，而破折号似乎……它滑入了印刷的新时代，却不一定有强大的舆论支持。所以也许它看起来更灵活。
There was freedom to experiment in its use, which is exactly what happened when it got mixed up in the theatrical milieu of 16th and 17th century Elizabethan England. No, you unnatural haggs! I will have such revenges on you both and all the world children. I will do such things. What they are, yet I know not, but they shall be the terrors of the earth. There's a technique in theatre called Aposio Pesis,
它的使用有实验的自由，这正是它在16和17世纪伊丽莎白时代英国戏剧界中被混用时所发生的情况。“不，你们这些不自然的巫婆！我要对你们俩以及全世界的孩子进行报复。我要做这样的事。它们是什么，我还不知道，但它们将是地球的恐怖。”戏剧中有一种技巧叫“中断法”，
which is an ancient Greek term for speech that is deliberately broken off mid-sentence. Use sparingly, it can add dramatic effect to dialogue. Sort of like... This. Playwrights use the dash in writing to indicate thinking pauses, interruptions, mid-speech realisations, or changes of subject for their actors. One rather famous playwright was quite fond of it.
这是一个古希腊术语，指故意在句子中间中断的演讲。适度使用，可以为对话增加戏剧效果。有点像……这样。剧作家在写作中使用破折号来表示演员的思考停顿、打断、演讲中的顿悟或话题转换。一位相当著名的剧作家非常喜欢它。
Shakespeare's first folio is a really good example where people are cut off when they lose their train of thought. It uses quite a lot of dashes. I think because it gives a bit of flexibility, it gets a bit more expressiveness than full stops and commas and colons and so on. Are they informed of this, my breath and blood fiery, The fiery Duke, tell the hot Duke that, no, but not yet, maybe he is not well. King Lear, as performed by Sir John Gilgird in 1994, a character facing the demons of old age,
莎士比亚的第一对开本是一个很好的例子，人们在失去思路时会被打断。它使用了相当多的破折号。我认为是因为它提供了一点灵活性，比句号、逗号、冒号等更具表现力。“他们知道这件事吗，我的呼吸和血液火热，火热的公爵，告诉那个暴躁的公爵，不，但还不是时候，也许他身体不适。”《李尔王》，由约翰·吉尔古德爵士于1994年表演，一个面对老年恶魔的角色，
bad decisions, and ungrateful children. In other words, someone who might get lost in his thoughts more than most. Using Dashes to show Apacio Pieces has remained a staple of stage writing, But around 100 years after Shakespeare in the early 18th century, an emerging branch of the literary arts elevated it from mere stage direction to a featured performer. Yeah, so I guess if playwrights had used the dash to imply how a speaker was performing these words, I suppose, for novelists, it was also used to indicate how someone, the cadence of how someone was speaking, to try and bring that to life a little bit. The novel as a literary form was, well, novel.
糟糕的决定和不孝的子女。换句话说，一个比大多数人更容易迷失在思绪中的人。使用破折号来表现“中断法”一直是舞台写作的主食。但在莎士比亚之后大约100年的18世纪初，文学艺术的一个新兴分支将其从单纯的舞台指导提升为特色表演。“是的，所以我想如果剧作家使用破折号来暗示说话者是如何表演这些台词的，我想，对于小说家来说，它也被用来表示某人说话的节奏，试图让它稍微生动一点。”小说作为一种文学形式，嗯，是新颖的。
It was a brand new form of writing, with stylistic conventions that broke away from classical rules of literature. Writers at the time explored authentic fictional characters with complex inner thoughts and naturalistic ways of speaking. And the M-Dash was how early novelists attempted to capture that. The dash became a really handy device to create the sense of someone almost dictating their adventures onto the page. Nowhere is this more obvious than a rambling satirical novel called Tristram Shandy, written by Lawrence Stern in 1759. With us, you see, the case is quite different. We are all ups and downs in this matter. Dash.
这是一种全新的写作形式，其风格惯例打破了古典文学规则。当时的作家探索了具有复杂内心思想和自然说话方式的真实虚构人物。而破折号正是早期小说家试图捕捉这一点的方式。破折号成为了一种非常方便的工具，可以创造出一种某人几乎是在将他们的冒险经历口述到纸上的感觉。这一点在一本叫作《项狄传》的漫谈式讽刺小说中表现得最为明显，该书由劳伦斯·斯特恩于1759年撰写。“对我们来说，你看，情况完全不同。在这件事上我们都有起有落。破折号。”
You are a great genius. Dash. Or tis fifty to one, sir, that you are a great dunce and a blockhead. Dash. Not that there is a total want of intimate. immediate steps? Dash? No.
“你是个伟大的天才。破折号。”“或者，先生，有五十比一的可能是你是个伟大的笨蛋和傻瓜。破折号。”“并不是说完全缺乏亲密的、直接的步骤？破折号？”“不。”
Dash? We're not so irregular as that comes to. Dash. But the two extremes are more common and in a greater degree in this unsettled island. This short excerpt has seven dashes in it, and it's used in every which way. In its wayward, dash-drew madness, it feels like Tristram Shandy is a fully rounded and totally flawed human being. there had been nothing like it before in English literature.
“破折号？”“我们还没那么不规则。破折号。”“但这两个极端在这个动荡的岛屿上更为常见，程度也更深。”这段简短的摘录中有七个破折号，而且以各种方式使用。在它任性、充满破折号的疯狂中，感觉《项狄传》是一个完全圆满且完全有缺陷的人。在英国文学史上，此前从未有过这样的作品。
You know, someone like Stern when he's writing Tristram Shandy, he's jumping in and out of thoughts. He's trying to commit this almost stream of consciousness narrative to paper. And it feels like it could have been written yesterday. I don't know what it is. There's something about the kind of the verve, the kind of the gusto behind it. It must have been like a bolt from it.
你知道，像斯特恩这样的人在写《项狄传》时，他的思绪跳进跳出。他试图将这种近乎意识流的叙事付诸纸上。感觉它就像是昨天写的一样。我不知道那是什么。它有一种活力，一种背后的热情。这对当时的人们来说一定像是一道晴天霹雳。
the blue. It must have been so incredible for people at the time to read this. But novelists didn't stop there. Another way they used the dash to convey the illusion of reality was by using the dash to censor sensitive content. It wasn't just for the sort of the sake of pruriance. It was also to give a sense of authenticity, I think, to sort of titillate readers a little bit. In a world dominated by nonfiction, these early writers were using every trick in the book to be taken seriously and make their make-believe stories feel believable. One of the ways they did this was by writing as if the fictional narrative actually took place. Novels were commonly written in the first person as if they were letters, diary entries,
它对当时的人们来说一定非常不可思议。但小说家并没有就此止步。他们使用破折号来传达现实幻觉的另一种方式是使用破折号来审查敏感内容。这不仅仅是为了某种淫秽的目的。我认为，这也是为了给读者一种真实感，稍微挑逗一下读者。在一个非虚构作品占主导地位的世界里，这些早期作家利用书中的每一个技巧来获得认真对待，并使他们的虚构故事感觉可信。他们这样做的方法之一是像虚构叙事真的发生过一样写作。小说通常以第一人称书写，就像它们是信件、日记条目，
or memoirs to create a sense that it was a real account. Oftentimes names, locations, and dates were censored by dashes, sometimes to protect the identity of a real person. but more often to act as if they were protecting the identity of a real person, adding the spice of factualness to an otherwise fictional story. So you might see someone's name, you might see the first letter of their name followed by a few dashes. One writer who used the dash in this way was Jane Austen. In Pride and Prejudice, published in 1813, the arrival of the handsome Wickham
或回忆录，以创造一种它是真实记录的感觉。通常名字、地点和日期会被破折号审查，有时是为了保护真实人物的身份，但更多时候是为了假装他们在保护真实人物的身份，给原本虚构的故事增添事实的调味。所以你可能会看到某人的名字，你可能会看到他们名字的第一个字母后面跟着几个破折号。简·奥斯汀就是一位以这种方式使用破折号的作家。在1813年出版的《傲慢与偏见》中，英俊的威克姆的到来
causes a stir in the fictional town of Merriton. But Wickham is not all that he's... scenes. And when his character is introduced, Austin uses dashes to redact the letters in the name of the army regiment he is about to join, as if that information was scrubbed from the record. Yes, she doesn't want to impugn the reputation of his military regiment, I think, is what she's trying to get across. And again, it's in the service of, I guess, of dramatic realism or the perception of realism here. I couldn't possibly say that thing. These are honourable. and apart from Wickham, who isn't.
在虚构的梅里顿镇引起了轰动。但威克姆并非他所表现的那样……当他的角色被介绍时，奥斯汀使用破折号来删减他即将加入的军队团名的字母，就好像该信息已从记录中抹去一样。“是的，她不想玷污他的军事团的声誉，我想这就是她试图表达的意思。同样，这是为了戏剧现实主义或这里的现实主义感知服务。”“我不可能说那件事。这些是光荣的，除了威克姆，他不是。”
The added delight for consumers of these novels was working out the hidden meaning behind the saucy little dash, a tantalizing mystery that promised to be revealed with a careful read. So as well as adding realism to a story, the dash as a censoring device was a clever piece of marketing,
这些小说消费者额外获得的乐趣是找出那诱人的小破折号背后的隐藏含义，这是一个承诺通过仔细阅读就能揭开的诱人谜团。因此，除了为故事增加现实感外，作为审查工具的破折号也是一种巧妙的营销手段，
helping sell these shiny new works of fiction to an increasingly literate population. And M-Dash use only exploded from there. According to 1-2018, academic study, dash usage in the English language rose sharply in the 19th century. If there was a golden age for the dash, this was it. Charles Dickens was relatively stingy. Oliver Twist has 703 dashes or one dash every 224 words. Herman Melville was undoubtedly a fan. Moby Dick clocks in with one dash every 129 words.
帮助将这些闪亮的新虚构作品卖给日益识字的人口。从那以后，破折号的使用量激增。根据2018年的一项学术研究，英语中破折号的使用在19世纪急剧上升。如果破折号有一个黄金时代，那就是现在。查尔斯·狄更斯相对吝啬。《雾都孤儿》有703个破折号，即每224个单词中有一个破折号。赫尔曼·梅尔维尔无疑是粉丝。《白鲸》中每129个单词就有一个破折号。
And Jane Eyre, Charlotte Bronte's masterpiece. piece, one dash every 90. A lot of this widespread adoption caught on because of how versatile the M-Dash can be. At this very core, the M-Dash signifies a visual pause on the page. And so in that way, it could easily stand in for other grammatical pauses, like the comma or colon or semicolon, except, you know, a little more fun. It's such a useful thing. It allows you to do a kind of a U-turn within a sentence.
而夏洛蒂·勃朗特的杰作《简·爱》，每90个单词就有一个。这种广泛采用很大程度上是因为破折号的多功能性。在最核心的地方，破折号标志着页面上的视觉停顿。因此，它可以很容易地代替其他语法停顿，如逗号、冒号或分号，只是，你知道，更有趣一点。它太有用了。它允许你在句子中进行一种“掉头”。
I've heard it describe this being useful for special effects. when you want to introduce a real change in tone or sentiment or direction, or when you want to set up a punchline, for example. But importantly, the MDASH was a punctuation mark that could make a sentence feel more human. In real life, we are naturally changing thoughts, cutting off others or cutting off ourselves. And one American poet would come to be defined by this punctuation mark more than any other, using them not for the way we talk, but to fathom the workings of a human mind. Much madness is divinest sense to a discerning eye, much sense the starkest madness.
我听说它被描述为对特效很有用。当你想要引入语调、情感或方向的真正改变时，或者当你想要设置一个妙语时，例如。但重要的是，破折号是一种能让句子感觉更人性化的标点符号。在现实生活中，我们自然会改变想法，打断别人或打断自己。而一位美国诗人将比任何其他标点符号更能被这个标点符号所定义，使用它们不是为了我们说话的方式，而是为了探测人类心灵的运作。“许多疯狂是洞察力眼中最神圣的理智，许多理智是最彻底的疯狂。”
Tis the majority in this as all prevails. Ascent and you are saying, Dimmer, you're straightway dangerous and handled with a chain. That is the dash-laden poetry of Emily Dickinson, as read by my former English professor. at Cambridge. So my name's Fiona Green. I'm a fellow at Jesus College and a lecturer at the English faculty and I've been here for about 30 years,
“在这一点上，大多数人占了上风。同意，你就被视为理智，反对，你立刻就危险了，会被锁链锁住。”那是艾米莉·狄金森充满破折号的诗歌，由我在剑桥大学的前英语教授朗读。“我叫菲奥娜·格林。我是耶稣学院的研究员，也是英语系的讲师，我在这里待了大约30年了，
if you can believe it. And I've done a lot of work on Dickinson and she's one of my favourite poets. How we doing? Perfect. Dickinson wrote nearly 1,800 poems in Amherst, Massachusetts, many of them composed during the Civil War.
如果你能相信的话。我做了很多关于狄金森的研究，她是我的最爱诗人之一。”“我们做得怎么样？”“完美。”狄金森在马萨诸塞州阿默斯特写了近1800首诗，其中许多是在内战期间创作的。
She put into verse the challenges of life, death and everything in between accompanied by thousands of dashes. Some of them are very easy and straightforward and have obviously obvious reference, but some of them don't make any sense. And some of them seem to represent a mind that's absolutely at odds with itself.
她将生活、死亡以及其间的一切挑战写成诗句，并伴随着成千上万个破折号。其中一些非常简单直接，有明显的指代，但有些则毫无意义。有些似乎代表了一个与自己完全不一致的心灵。
So sometimes they come midline, they just come like a parenthetical dash with one word in between two lines. It's a void where we can pour in our... ideas? That makes it sound really sloppy, and I don't think she's a sloppy thinker. I think that she's a quick, quick thinker. Dickinson used dashes to quickly move on to the next thought, caring less about completion than pinning down her unique insights of the human experience onto paper. She exploited unfinishedness, right? And that the poems are always in the
所以有时它们出现在行中，它们就像一个括号式的破折号，两行之间有一个词。这是一个我们可以倾注我们的……想法的虚空？这听起来很草率，我不认为她是一个草率的思考者。我认为她是一个快速、快速的思考者。狄金森使用破折号来快速进入下一个想法，比起完成，她更关心将她对人类体验的独特见解钉在纸上。她利用了未完成性，对吧？诗歌总是处于
process, always undecided and always in the process of making and kind of never finished. And in that story, the dash and that suspendedness, that suspendedness of decision over punctuation is part of the unfinishedness of the poem. It's not clear to me that she was writing something primarily, if at all, for publication. Dickinson never gave a reason for using dashes instead of other punctuation marks, leading to decades of academic inquiry and speculation. It feels as though she used the flexibility of the dash to introduce even more ambiguity to a poem's meaning.
过程中，总是未决的，总是处于制作过程中，而且永远不会完成。在那个故事中，破折号和那种悬置感，那种对标点符号决定的悬置感，是诗歌未完成性的一部分。我不清楚她是否主要是为了出版而写东西。狄金森从未给出使用破折号而不是其他标点符号的理由，导致了数十年的学术探究和猜测。感觉她似乎利用了破折号的灵活性，为诗歌的意义引入了更多的歧义。
So there's a very famous poem called Publication is the auction of the mind of man. Can you read it? So publication is the auction of the mind of man, poverty be justifying for so foul a thing, possibly. But we would rather, from our Garrett go, white unto the white creator than invest our snow. I mean, I noticed when you read it, you kind of, you did run over a few dashes.
所以有一首非常有名的诗叫《出版是人类心灵的拍卖》。你能读一下吗？“所以出版是人类心灵的拍卖，贫穷是为如此肮脏的事情辩护，可能。但我们宁愿从我们的阁楼走出去，白白走向白色的创造者，而不是投资我们的雪。”我的意思是，我注意到你读的时候，你确实略过了几个破折号。
Well, but listen, how would you read it? Read it with the dashes, read the dashes out loud. How do they sound? Well, publication is the auction of the mind of man. Poverty, be justifying for so foul a thing. So you're assuming that a dashes, is a pause. And yet we've also said that a dash is a way of moving quickly. And what is actually overriding any kind of punctuation is the metre. We know how it goes. Publication is the
嗯，但是听着，你会怎么读它？带着破折号读，大声读出破折号。它们听起来怎么样？“嗯，出版是人类心灵的拍卖。贫穷，是为如此肮脏的事情辩护。”所以你假设破折号是一个停顿。然而我们也说过，破折号是一种快速移动的方式。而实际上凌驾于任何标点符号之上的是格律。我们知道它是怎么走的。“出版是”
auction of the mind of man. Poverty be justifying for so foul a thing. So the metrical frame overrides any kind of punctuation, particularly when it's this very familiar ballad form. So the dash is to be seen and read? Yeah. You can't hear the dashes. mind-blown. That's so often 25 years ago. When Emily Dickinson died in 1886 at the age of 55, her handwritten poems were edited and published by Mabel Lewis Todd and Thomas Wentworth Higginson. They gave the poem's titles, capitalized words, and crucially removed most of her dashes. Look, I know I am reducing her mind-altering verse to a set of statistics, but I've counted all the dashes left out in the first collection of poems
“人类心灵的拍卖。贫穷是为如此肮脏的事情辩护。”所以格律框架凌驾于任何标点符号之上，特别是当它是这种非常熟悉的民谣形式时。所以破折号是用来被看见和阅读的？是的。你听不到破折号。太震撼了。那是25年前的事了。当艾米莉·狄金森于1886年去世，享年55岁时，她的手写诗歌由梅布尔·路易斯·托德和托马斯·温特沃斯·希金森编辑并出版。他们给诗歌起了标题，大写了单词，最重要的是，删除了她大部分的破折号。看，我知道我正在将她改变心灵的诗句简化为一组统计数据，但我统计了第一部诗集中遗漏的所有破折号。
Todd and Higginson published in 1890. Out of the 1,151 dashes, they kept just 52 of them. That's a big, big change to how the poems look on the page, even if, as Fiona says, it didn't change how they were read out. I think they put her into circulation in a way that was legible to a 19th century audience. Yes, so it looks to us like a hatchet job, but it looks to that readership in the 1890s as something familiar, something they can read.
托德和希金森在1890年出版了它。在1151个破折号中，他们只保留了52个。这对诗歌在页面上的外观是一个非常、非常大的改变，即使正如菲奥娜所说，这并没有改变它们的朗读方式。我认为他们以一种对19世纪读者来说可读的方式将她推向了流通。是的，所以对我们来说这看起来像是一次拙劣的修改，但对1890年代的读者群来说，这看起来很熟悉，是他们能读懂的东西。
It's avant-garde, it's strange, it's unusual. And it doesn't feel like 19th century thinking in lots of ways. Her first posthumous collection was a sensation, and her poems have never gone out of print. But it was not the first time in English literary history, grammar purists felt that the dash count was too high for the times. Ever since the M-Dash became a widely adopted punctuation mark, it is faced backlash. A century before Dickinson, Jonathan Swift, mocked excessive use of the dash by contemporary writers
它是前卫的，它是奇怪的，它是不寻常的。而且在很多方面它感觉不像19世纪的思想。她的第一部遗作集引起了轰动，她的诗歌从未绝版。但这并不是英语文学史上第一次语法纯粹主义者认为破折号的数量对那个时代来说太多了。自从破折号成为广泛采用的标点符号以来，它就面临着反弹。在狄金森之前的一个世纪，乔纳森·斯威夫特在长篇讽刺诗中嘲笑了当代作家对破折号的过度使用。
in a long satirical poem. In modern wit, all printed trash is set off with numerous breaks and dashes. Almost a century later, an anonymous reviewer for the British critic said this about a poem by Lord Byron. We must protest against the effect of dashes, which occur without any reason whatsoever, sometimes twice or thrice in one line and nevertheless than a dozen times in a page. And while Jane Austen's dashes may have titillated her readers, with her editors, it was a different story. Recently, a writer and comedian named Cressy Cornus spent two years studying the dashes in Jane Austen's published and unpublished works, and she estimates that over 6,000 M dashes were edited out from prize.
“在现代智慧中，所有印刷的垃圾都带有无数的断裂和破折号。”近一个世纪后，《英国评论家》的一位匿名评论家对拜伦勋爵的一首诗这样评价：“我们必须抗议破折号的影响，它们毫无理由地出现，有时一行中出现两次或三次，一页中不少于十几次。”虽然简·奥斯汀的破折号可能挑逗了她的读者，但对于她的编辑来说，情况就不同了。最近，一位名叫克雷西·科努斯的作家兼喜剧演员花了两年时间研究简·奥斯汀已出版和未出版作品中的破折号，她估计有超过6000个破折号被从《傲慢与偏见》中编辑掉了。
in prejudice. It's easy to overuse the dash. Keith Houston again. It's a really useful mark. I have to do it myself. I mean, I know Jane Austen but I do have to self-edit to stop myself using it all the time.
过度使用破折号很容易。又是基思·休斯顿。“这是一个非常有用的符号。我自己也得这样做。我的意思是，我知道简·奥斯汀，但我确实必须自我编辑，以阻止自己一直使用它。”
Even today, modern guardians of grammar like the Chicago Manual of Style warn writers like Keith against dash overusage with the catchy rhyme, if in doubt, edit them out. Even Fiona Green, my professor and Emily Dickinson Maven, believes that as versatile as it is, other more targeted punctuation
即使在今天，像《芝加哥格式手册》这样的现代语法守护者也会用朗朗上口的韵律警告像基思这样的作家不要过度使用破折号：“如有疑问，删掉它们。”即使是菲奥娜·格林，我的教授和艾米莉·狄金森专家，也认为尽管它很通用，但其他更有针对性的标点符号
can be necessary for clarity. I was thinking of certain prose writers, I better not say, who I think use the dash so as to sound lyrical and ought to be more decisive about what they're saying. It's kind of multipurpose, but it's also a way of not making decisions. I would say, well, what exactly is the connection between this thought and that thought? I need to know if it's a semicolon or a comma because then there's a different thought being expressed and a different articulation,
对于清晰度来说可能是必要的。“我想到了一些散文作家，我最好别说名字，我认为他们使用破折号是为了听起来抒情，但应该对他们所说的话更果断。它是一种多用途的符号，但也是一种不作决定的方式。我会说，嗯，这个想法和那个想法之间的确切联系是什么？我需要知道它是分号还是逗号，因为那样就会表达出不同的想法和不同的衔接，”
which means a joining together of thoughts. As far as punctuation is concerned, the MDASH could be a bit divisive, and for centuries, critics, editors, technical writers, and authors of various op-eds have opined over whether it's a mark of lazy grammar. But divisive or not, that never stopped Great Reworthy. writers like Henry James, Jack Kerouac, or Brian Vance from Stump Town Savings from using it in spades.
这意味着将思想连接在一起。就标点符号而言，破折号可能有点引起分歧，几个世纪以来，评论家、编辑、技术作家和各种评论文章的作者都在争论它是否是懒惰语法的标志。但无论是否引起分歧，这从未阻止像亨利·詹姆斯、杰克·凯鲁亚克或“树桩镇储蓄”的布莱恩·万斯这样伟大的作家大量使用它。
You know, let me read one of those entries again. So safe catch elite wild can tuna, comma, select varieties, M-Dash, 2 for 6. And I'm doing that deliberately because I'm trying to really call out the pricing separate from the item to like make that stand out. Clearly, Brian is and always will be a fan of the M-Dash, which is why he was dismayed in. 2025 when the MDASH got dragged into the debate about whether it's a clear signal that the text was written by AI. A lot of what I had been seeing over the past six months, really, is that, you know, the MDash is a dead giveaway that someone's using chat GBT.
“你知道，让我再读一遍那些条目。所以，‘安全捕获野生罐装金枪鱼，逗号，精选品种，破折号，2瓶6美元。’我这样做是故意的，因为我试图真正把价格从商品中区分出来，让它脱颖而出。”显然，布莱恩现在是，将来也永远是破折号的粉丝，这就是为什么他在2025年当破折号被卷入关于它是否是文本由人工智能编写的明确信号的辩论时感到沮丧。“过去六个月我所看到的大部分内容，确实是，你知道，破折号是某人使用ChatGPT的铁证。”
But some people see an M dash probably for, you know, the hundredth time this week, and they instantly assume chat GPT wrote that. People around the internet started to notice that many people around the internet started to notice that Many large language models like chat GPT have the tendency to deploy the end dash with reckless abandon. It was to the point that some, well, younger generations who might be more attuned to reading emails and text messages, began referring to it as something else. Chat GPT hyphen is getting a lot of stick at the moment, okay? Pretty little thing recently had a rebrand.
“但有些人可能一周内第一百次看到破折号，他们立刻假设是ChatGPT写的。”互联网上的人们开始注意到，许多大型语言模型（如ChatGPT）有肆无忌惮地部署破折号的倾向。以至于一些可能更习惯阅读电子邮件和短信的年轻一代开始称它为别的东西。“ChatGPT连字符现在正受到很多抨击，好吗？Pretty Little Thing最近进行了品牌重塑。”
The top most light comment was someone being like, I can't believe they let chat chach chviness. It's a longer hyphen. I don't know if you've noticed it. that we've been given and yeah, everyone should take it. Public service announcement, take out the hyphen. This mark that was so heavily relied upon by the likes of Charlotte Bronte and Emily Dickinson is now being referred to as the chat GPT hyphen. That is how much people are connecting it
“最热门的评论是有人说，‘我不敢相信他们让ChatGPT写这个。’这是一个更长的连字符。我不知道你有没有注意到。我们被赋予了它，是的，每个人都应该接受它。公共服务公告，去掉连字符。”这个曾经被夏洛蒂·勃朗特和艾米莉·狄金森等作家严重依赖的符号，现在被称为“ChatGPT连字符”。这就是人们将它与人工智能联系起来的程度。
with artificial intelligence. So how is it that a punctuation mark used for hundreds of years to make writing feel more human became a capture for machine-generated text? When Theo Vaughn asked Sam Altman, the boss of OpenAI, about this on his podcast, Altman claimed he added the dashes for lulls. Why does Chad UbT have that hyphen thing? You know, we have this team that figures out what the model's personality should be like and how it should behave.
那么，一个使用了数百年的、让写作感觉更人性化的标点符号，是如何成为机器生成文本的捕获器的呢？当西奥·沃恩在播客上问OpenAI的老板萨姆·奥特曼这个问题时，奥特曼声称他为了停顿而增加了破折号。“为什么ChatGPT有那个连字符的东西？”“你知道，我们有一个团队来确定模型的个性应该是什么样的，以及它应该如何表现。”
And a lot of users like m-dashes. So we had more m-dashes. And now I think we have too many m-dashes. But that's the answer. It was just like, users liked it. We put more in. Now it's like a little bit of a meme. and it's quite annoying to me. We should fix that.
“而且很多用户喜欢破折号。所以我们增加了更多的破折号。现在我想我们有太多的破折号了。但这就是答案。它只是像，用户喜欢它。我们放了更多。现在它有点像个梗，这让我很烦。我们应该修复它。”
It's not entirely clear whether Altman's telling us the whole story, and industry insiders like Sean Geddica believe it's much more complicated than that. It's surprisingly hard to find the answer. There's not the kind of consensus on the topic that you would expect for something so observable. Certainly all of the closed models, i.e. all of the best models, or the process of training them is a trade secret. Sean says that this is a pretty recent phenomenon, and that chat GPT hasn't always used a lot of MDashes in its writing.
奥特曼是否告诉了我们全部真相尚不完全清楚，像肖恩·格迪卡这样的行业内部人士认为这比那复杂得多。“很难找到答案。对于如此明显的事情，并没有人们预期的那种共识。当然，所有的封闭模型，即所有最好的模型，或者训练它们的过程都是商业机密。”肖恩说这是一个相当近期的现象，ChatGPT并不总是使用大量的破折号。
So GPT 3.5 came out in November 2022 and didn't use a lot of MDashes. Around that time, OpenAI's language model had mostly been trained on publicly available data around the web, things like websites, articles, blogs, pirated books, around 600,000 Enron emails, probably not a ton of m-dashes used in those Enron emails. And then July 2024, by that time, the models were producing a lot of m-dashes. So there's this kind of, you know, just under two-year window. Chat GPT users all began to notice not just that m-dashes were frequently used, but that the LLM wouldn't stop using it.
“所以GPT 3.5在2022年11月发布时并没有使用大量的破折号。大约在那个时候，OpenAI的语言模型主要是在网络上公开可用的数据上进行训练的，比如网站、文章、博客、盗版书籍，大约60万封安然公司的电子邮件，可能那些安然公司的电子邮件中并没有使用大量的破折号。然后是2024年7月，到那时，模型正在产生大量的破折号。所以有这样一种，你知道，不到两年的窗口期。”ChatGPT用户都开始注意到，不仅破折号被频繁使用，而且大语言模型不会停止使用它。
Numerous open AI and Reddit threads from frustrated users claim that no matter how much they prompted to avoid m-dashes, the AI would insert them back in. Sean wondered what was going on in that time frame that led to the emergence of the MDASH, and in June 2025 he got the clue he needed. Anthropic, the company behind the LLM Claude and one of OpenAI's main competitors, were forced to reveal their methods in a lawsuit. These companies began to search for more data,
来自沮丧用户的众多OpenAI和Reddit帖子声称，无论他们如何提示避免使用破折号，人工智能都会把它们插回去。肖恩想知道在那段时间里发生了什么导致了破折号的出现，在2025年6月，他得到了他需要的线索。Anthropic，大语言模型Claude背后的公司，也是OpenAI的主要竞争对手之一，在一场诉讼中被迫披露了他们的方法。这些公司开始寻找更多数据，
and in particular they searched for print books, print books from older decades that perhaps weren't as represented in the printoutes, in the previous training data. Court documents have shown that Anthropic aimed to expand the language model not just by feeding an information that was publicly available on the web, but quite literally, all the books in the world.
特别是他们搜索了印刷书籍，来自旧年代的印刷书籍，这些书籍在之前的训练数据中可能没有得到充分体现。法庭文件显示，Anthropic旨在通过不仅输入网络上公开可用的信息，而且字面上输入世界上所有的书籍来扩展语言模型。
In a process called destructive scanning, Anthropic bought millions of books, cut the pages out of their bindings, and digitize them to feed Claude. Sean suspects the model's ravenous appetite for words most likely included all of the great authors of our time, M-Dashes and all. Again, this is pure speculation on my book.
在一个叫作“破坏性扫描”的过程中，Anthropic购买了数百万本书，将书页从装订中切下，并将它们数字化以喂给Claude。肖恩怀疑模型对文字的贪婪胃口很可能包括了我们这个时代所有的伟大作家，包括破折号在内。“同样，这纯粹是我的猜测。”
They kind of picked up the stylistic habits of these like classic literature texts, which seem very incongruous when people use them today to write emails and job applications and that kind of thing. So if you were to train language models on a bunch of late 1800s, early 1900s English, they might end up using M-Dashers as much as those books do, which today would seem like overuse. And with that, the dash has now passed. from the hand of Shakespeare into the vast data centers of this new age. It is, of course, reductive to assume any bit of writing that contains an MDash was written by AI.
“它们吸收了这些经典文学文本的风格习惯，当人们今天用它们来写电子邮件和求职申请之类的事情时，这看起来非常不协调。所以如果你要用一堆1800年代末、1900年代初的英语来训练语言模型，它们最终可能会像那些书一样频繁地使用破折号，这在今天看来就像是过度使用。”就这样，破折号现在已经从莎士比亚的手中传递到了这个新时代的庞大数据中心。当然，假设任何包含破折号的写作都是由人工智能编写的，这是一种简化。
In fact, the reason why LLM's add MDash is to generate a text is because it's a mark that we have used for literally hundreds of years in published writing. At least for now, there's still subtle hints that a piece of writing has been composed using AI, a formal tone, specific vocabulary words, a certain kind of beigeness to the writing itself. But there is something about that long, elegant dash on a page that makes it easy to pick out and pick on. It's an easy mark. The M-Dash may have gotten unfairly caught up in the bigger existential dread around AI. It goes without saying, though, that there are bigger issues at stake than ruminating over a piece of punctuation, and not everyone has lost their focus or their minds.
事实上，大语言模型在生成文本时添加破折号的原因是，这是一个我们在出版写作中字面上使用了数百年的符号。至少目前，仍然有微妙的暗示表明一段文字是使用人工智能编写的：正式的语气、特定的词汇、写作本身某种程度上的平庸。但页面上那个长而优雅的破折号确实有一些东西，使它很容易被挑出来并被挑剔。这是一个容易的目标。破折号可能被不公平地卷入了围绕人工智能的更大存在主义恐惧中。不过不用说，比起反思一个标点符号，还有更大的问题悬而未决，而且并不是每个人都失去了焦点或理智。
Does punctuation really make people angry? I mean, there are so many things in the world to make you angry. As an educator, it's not necessarily spotting the difference between real and fake that gets Dr Fiona Green's blood boiling. What concerns her is that people don't seem to understand what they are surrendering when they allow AI to do the hard parts for them, that the hard parts are precisely what it is. it's all about.
“标点符号真的会让人生气吗？我的意思是，世界上有太多事情会让你生气了。”作为一名教育工作者，让菲奥娜·格林博士血压升高的不一定是发现真实和虚假之间的区别。她关心的是，人们似乎不明白当他们允许人工智能为他们做困难的部分时，他们正在放弃什么，即困难的部分正是它的全部意义所在。
The thought that you can save time, the machine will do it more quickly. What are you trying to get to? Everything that you read can matter. Every rabbit hole that you accidentally go down matters, misreading things and reading something boring and stopping halfway through and so on and so on. All of that is part of the study.
“你认为你可以节省时间，机器会更快地完成它。你试图达到什么目的？你读到的每一件事都很重要。你偶然进入的每一个兔子洞都很重要，误读东西，读一些无聊的东西，中途停下来等等等等。所有这些都是学习的一部分。”
You see these lights go on all the time, right? You went like this earlier, you know, mind blow. It changes the way people think. it rewires their brain. So why would we introduce a machine? Why would we outsource exactly that perfect moment to something else? It's the process of learning that then sends you out as a different human. In November of 2025, Sam Altman announced the news to M-Dash haters and lovers around the world.
“你总是看到这些灯亮起来，对吧？你刚才就这样做了，你知道，‘太震撼了’。它改变了人们的思考方式。它重塑了他们的大脑。那么我们为什么要引入一台机器？我们为什么要将那个完美的时刻外包给别的东西？正是学习的过程让你作为一个不同的人走出去。”2025年11月，萨姆·奥特曼向全世界的破折号仇恨者和爱好者宣布了消息。
Quote, small but happy when? If you tell chat GPT not to use M-Dash. in your custom instructions, it finally does what it's supposed to do. Perhaps with this update, some AI users will abandon dashes entirely, which I cannot say I am too cut up about. After all these years and after countless adventures together, the MDash belongs back with us humans. What's your favourite poem?
“引用：‘小但快乐的胜利。如果你告诉ChatGPT不要在你的自定义指令中使用破折号，它终于做了它应该做的事。’”也许随着这次更新，一些人工智能用户会完全放弃破折号，我不能说我对此感到太难过。经过这么多年的共同冒险，破折号应该回到我们人类手中。“你最喜欢的诗是什么？”
I do have a favourite. It starts, I felt a cleaving in my mind. You know that one? I don't. I asked Viona if she'd send us out with her favourite poem by Emily M-Dickinson. And in the unsure, maddening future we are heading towards, the choice felt appropriate. I felt a cleaving in my mind as if my brain had split. I tried to match it seam by seam but could not make them fit.
“我确实有一个最喜欢的。它开头是，‘我感到我的思想中有一种分裂。’你知道那首吗？”“我不知道。”我请菲奥娜用她最喜欢的艾米莉·狄金森的诗送我们离开。而在我们正走向的不确定、令人抓狂的未来中，这个选择感觉很合适。“我感到我的思想中有一种分裂，仿佛我的大脑已经裂开。我试图缝合它，缝合处对缝合处，却无法让它们吻合。”
The thought behind I strove to join unto the thought before, but sequence ravelled out of sound like balls upon the floor. Isn't that wild? Coming up, Will tells us me about one weapon in the battle against AI writing. Typography. Stay with us. So we're back with Will Aspinall. And in the main story, you talked about how the MDASH got caught up in the sort of existential dread that comes along with AI.
“我努力将思想与之前的思想连接起来，但序列在声音中解开了，就像地板上的球一样。”那不是很狂野吗？接下来，威尔告诉我们关于对抗人工智能写作的一种武器。排版。请留下来。所以我们回到了威尔·阿斯皮纳尔身边。在主故事中，你谈到了破折号是如何被卷入伴随人工智能而来的那种存在主义恐惧中的。
And there's been kind of this stigma associated with using the MDash, how it's the sort of like this smoke. smoking gun that if you see an M-Dash, it means that this thing was written by AI. And it's gotten to the point where people actively avoid using the punctuation because they're trying to avoid the accusation of using AI for their writing. But you're here because you want to talk about this really inventive design-led solution that's a more positive spin on this whole situation. Yeah, exactly. So instead of obsessively monitoring your M-Dash usage and taking steps to exterminate them, or, you know, perhaps like me, thumb your nose at the grammar place and actually up M-Dash use exponentially.
使用破折号（M-Dash）一直以来都带有一种污名，仿佛它就是某种“确凿证据”，一旦你看到破折号，就意味着这是AI写的。现在情况已经到了人们为了避免被指责使用AI写作而主动避开使用这种标点符号的地步。但你今天来这里，是想谈谈这个非常有创意的设计主导型解决方案，它为整个局面带来了一种更积极的视角。没错，正是这样。所以，与其强迫症般地监控你的破折号使用并试图消灭它们，或者像我一样对语法警察嗤之以鼻，反而成倍地增加破折号的使用。
A creative agency based in Sydney, Australia, called Cocoa Gun, has opted for another approach, a redesign of the M-Dash called the Am-Dash. Okay, so what is the Am-Dash exactly? So the Am-Dash is a new punctuation mark that you would use exactly like an M-Dash, for pauses, commas, as a colon, or just for some dramatic flare. But it looks a little different. So here's a picture. Can you see that, Roman?
一家位于澳大利亚悉尼的创意代理公司 Cocoa Gun 选择了一种不同的方法，他们重新设计了破折号，称之为“Am-Dash”。好的，那么 Am-Dash 到底是什么？Am-Dash 是一种新的标点符号，你的用法和破折号完全一样，用于停顿、逗号、冒号，或者仅仅是为了增加一点戏剧性的效果。但它看起来有点不同。这是一张照片。你能看到吗，罗曼？
Yes. So this is like the M-Dash, it's this long bar. But, you know, at the left end, it kind of curves down and the right end it curves up. It's kind of like an M-Dash with seraphs on it, sort of like a tilde. Exactly, yeah. And my initial reaction was it looks like one of those kind of suave 20s-style pencil moustaches. So the idea is that you put one or more of these babies in your writing instead of an M-Dash, and you'll never be confused for a machine or be accused. of using one, because it's its very scarcity is that what makes it AI proof. Because language models go on probability, the likelihood of chat GPT using an Amdash instead of an M is infinitesimally small. Is there a way of making a statement? Is it a bit of a, I don't mean a human fight back in a kind of like, yeah, let's man the fences and kind of tear down the hour river and all that kind of thing. But just to make a pointed comment on where we are in culture with this thing.
是的。它就像破折号一样，是一条长横线。但是，你知道，在左端它向下弯曲，右端向上弯曲。它有点像带有衬线的破折号，看起来像个波浪号。没错，确实。我最初的反应是它看起来像那种20年代风度翩翩的铅笔胡子。所以这个想法是，你在写作中使用一个或多个这种小东西来代替破折号，你就永远不会被误认为是机器，也不会被指责使用AI，因为它的稀缺性正是它能防AI的原因。因为语言模型是基于概率的，ChatGPT 使用 Am-Dash 而不是破折号的可能性微乎其微。这是一种表达立场的方式吗？这是否有点像，我不是指那种人类的反击，比如“让我们守住防线，推倒高墙”之类的，而仅仅是对我们当前文化处境的一种尖锐评论？
That's Aunt Melda, the co-founder of Coca-Gun in Sydney. He said that the Amdash came about in trying to find the appropriate response to the rise of AI writing. We wanted it to be rooted in a real love of writing. It just kind of really sucks that people would outsource all writing to a machine, to an algorithm. Okay, so if I'm understanding this correctly, using an Am-Dash instead of an Am-Dash, It's kind of this symbolic way to signal that the text that I am writing has been typed up by me, a human, because an LLM wouldn't ever think to insert an AmDash. That's right. That's right.
那是悉尼 Cocoa Gun 的联合创始人安特·梅尔达（Ant Melda）。他说，Am-Dash 的出现是为了寻找应对AI写作兴起的适当回应。我们希望它植根于对写作的真正热爱。人们把所有的写作都外包给机器、外包给算法，这真的很糟糕。好的，如果我理解得没错，使用 Am-Dash 而不是破折号，这是一种象征性的方式，用来表明我正在写的文本是由我——一个人类——打出来的，因为大语言模型永远不会想到插入一个 Am-Dash。没错，就是这样。
So how does one even use an AmDash? Like, I didn't know, I didn't know such a thing existed. Like, how do you actually insert it into whatever word processor you're using? Okay. So, yeah, to get it requires downloading two fonts developed by Coca-Gun. They're called Times New Human, which is the serif option, and A-Real, which is the, the songs. Okay. They're doing a whole thing here. Okay. Yeah, there's a lot of puns in this. There's a lot of puns, which I love. I love a good pun. And then to use it, you simply type Am and
那么一个人该如何使用 Am-Dash 呢？我以前根本不知道有这种东西存在。你到底是怎么把它插入到你正在使用的文字处理软件里的？好的。要使用它，需要下载两个由 Cocoa Gun 开发的字体。它们分别叫“Times New Human”（衬线选项）和“A-Real”（无衬线选项）。好的。他们在这里玩了一整套梗。好的。是的，这里有很多双关语。有很多双关语，我喜欢。我喜欢好的双关语。然后要使用它，你只需输入“Am”和
hyphen, and it'll insert that little moustache dash into your work. So to replace the M dash with the Am takes a very human type commitment. And that is one of the reasons I really, really like this idea. It's the sheer eccentric humanity of this project. it's, okay, it's really, really low stakes. But the response has surprised Ant with thousands of downloads since its release in May 2025. We didn't really think we'd get that many downloads. We thought there'd be maybe a couple of hundred and that'd be it.
连字符，它就会把那个小胡子破折号插入到你的作品中。所以，用 Am-Dash 替换破折号需要一种非常人性化的投入。这也是我非常非常喜欢这个想法的原因之一。这是该项目纯粹而古怪的人性。好吧，这确实没什么大不了的。但自2025年5月发布以来，数以千计的下载量让安特感到惊讶。我们真的没想到会有这么多下载。我们以为可能也就几百次，然后就结束了。
And the more it's used, every time someone uses it, that's kind of an example of, you know, that's another flag in the sand, I guess. So the real challenge for the Amdash is getting accepted by Unicode and being one of almost 160,000 characters in the current book. and Ant said that seeing the Amdash appear in the wild would really be a crowning achievement. If there was an article in the New York Times,
而且它被使用得越多，每当有人使用它，这就像是某种例子，我想，这是在沙滩上插下的另一面旗帜。所以 Am-Dash 面临的真正挑战是被 Unicode 采纳，成为当前书中近16万个字符中的一员。安特说，看到 Am-Dash 在现实中出现将是一个巅峰成就。如果《纽约时报》上有一篇文章，
like a headline in the New York Times, it would use the Amdash, that would be just, you know, dream come true. I'm helping out, Anne, because I showed it to Brian Vance of Stumptown Savings fame, and he was very taken with it. So, you know, who knows? If you're in the Portland, Oregon area,
比如《纽约时报》的标题，如果它使用了 Am-Dash，那简直就是梦想成真。我正在帮忙，安特，因为我把它展示给了以“Stumptown Savings”闻名的布莱恩·万斯（Brian Vance），他非常喜欢它。所以，谁知道呢？如果你在俄勒冈州的波特兰地区，
you might get to see the Amdash being used to highlight the low, low price of tuna. And that would be a really neat end to the all deal Brian's been through. But, you know, this brings to mind an issue, which is as it gets used out in the wild, then it does get picked up by LLMs, and then it would be regurgitated by, you know, some kind of AI composer. I mean, I would say there's a huge imbalance. This is a David and Goliath story, right?
你可能会看到 Am-Dash 被用来突出金枪鱼的超低价格。那将是布莱恩所经历的一切事情的一个非常好的结局。但是，这让我想到了一个问题，那就是随着它在现实中被使用，它会被大语言模型抓取，然后被某种AI作曲家复述。我的意思是，我认为存在巨大的不平衡。这是一个大卫与歌利亚的故事，对吧？
You know, currently the M dash is everywhere and a few little am dashes. I mean, you know, we might be very old men by the time that happens. I see. I see. So we can win these, you know, like battles right now and worry about the overall war later. That's it. The moment is now. Well, this is great.
你知道，目前破折号无处不在，而 Am-Dash 却很少。我的意思是，到那时我们可能已经是老头子了。我明白了。我明白了。所以我们现在可以赢得这些战斗，以后再担心整体战争。就是这样。时机就是现在。好吧，这太棒了。
Thank you so much for this story about the Amdash and its predecessor of the Amdash. This has been such a fun episode to make. I really appreciate it. Thank you, Roman. If you want to start using it, go to theamdash.com where there are links to downloading Times New Human. and a reel. Nice.
非常感谢你讲述关于 Am-Dash 及其前身破折号的故事。制作这一集真的很有趣。我真的很感激。谢谢你，罗曼。如果你想开始使用它，请访问 theamdash.com，那里有下载 Times New Human 和 A-Real 的链接。不错。
99% Invisible was reported this week by Will Aspinall and edited by Vivian Lay, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha, who did unfortunately need to hand-count the number of M-Dashes in Emily Dickinson's work for this story.
本周的《99% Invisible》由威尔·阿斯皮纳尔（Will Aspinall）报道，薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）配乐。事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙（Graham Hesha）完成，他为了这个故事不幸需要手工统计艾米莉·狄金森作品中破折号的数量。
I'm so sorry about that, Graham. Special thanks this week to Sam Byrne, who performed the readings of our literary characters, and to Grant Hutchinson for his illuminating page on the M-Dash on his website. OikaFuge.com. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
我很抱歉，格雷厄姆。本周特别感谢山姆·伯恩（Sam Byrne），他为我们的文学角色进行了朗读，还要感谢格兰特·哈钦森（Grant Hutchinson）在他网站 OikaFuge.com 上关于破折号的启发性页面。凯西·2（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perrube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lachamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, talent and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝（Chris Perrube）、杰森·德里昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉查马顿（Lachamadon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、塔伦（Talent）和雷恩·斯特拉德利（Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。
We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building. in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. For the record, this episode contained 68 m-dashes, which I believe earns us a three on the Dickinson M-dash scale. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 Series XM 播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦（Pandora Building），位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们新的 Discord 服务器。那里有链接，还有 99PI 的每一集往期节目，网址是 99PI.org。顺便提一下，这一集包含了68个破折号，我相信这让我们在狄金森破折号量表上获得了三分。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。